everyone's heard about microsoft but
have you ever thought about where
everything happens where is its
headquarters what does it look like is
it just a giant factory with a lot of
nerds and machines where should we start
there was so much to talk about for
example the giant mall inside microsoft
city the bill lake the high five
corridors the maker's garage or the
awesome building 87 where all sorts of
top-secret projects are under the
procedure
the microsoft campus
let's take it from the top and talk
about the location first back when bill
gates and paul allen wanted a place
where they could start their company
they chose a chicken farm in the suburbs
of seattle redmond washington in
february 1986 that chicken farm was
turned into six buildings that were like
the home of microsoft and to be very
precise the home of microsoft consisted
of six buildings these days the
microsoft campus spreads across 500
acres and has the capacity of thousands
of employees but you'll be making a huge
mistake if you think that stuff was like
this decades ago back when there were
only six buildings the employee capacity
was only 800 but these days about 50 000
people weren't there and we are not
including the visitors can you imagine
the massive growth at first there were
only six buildings but these days there
are 120 buildings on the microsoft
campus this is why it is almost
considered a tiny city and just like
universities it is called a campus
because it has dozens of buildings in it
now being the nerds they are initially
when there were only six buildings they
named the buildings numerically instead
of giving them a cool name now the
different spots in the microsoft campus
have interesting and quite amusing names
for example the high five hallway the
maker's garage the bill lake and the
commons are a few examples of how over
the years their ability to name
buildings has gotten a lot better
building 92
enough about names let's talk about what
goes on inside there first of all if you
are a tourist it is most likely that
your tour will begin from building 92.
is there a specific reason yes there
kind of is building 92 is considered as
the microsoft visitor center and it is
basically designed in a way that whoever
comes to visit the small universe whose
god is bill gates can take a look at the
best that microsoft has to offer since
there are 120 buildings and the campus
is spread across 500 acres walking on
foot and expecting to be as productive
as you want to is kind of silly
therefore to make stuff easier there are
several mini hybrid buses extremely
comfortable furnished and laced with
high-tech technology these buses make
sure that you get the best view of the
microsoft campus while being perfectly
comfortable in fact there is a special
poster on the bus that has a few qr
codes where you can digitally rate the
performance and your experience of the
hybrid minibuses
the company museum
once you're in building 92 the microsoft
visitor center make sure you visit the
company museum there you can find
important launches that were the reason
behind the immense success of microsoft
and relevant description in history now
if you get bored by looking at nerdy
stuff you can always play some awesome
games like forza racing and minecraft
etc and don't worry if you're not the
kind of person who plays games like
minecraft or messes around and happens
to be quite serious about their
professional life and how to make it
more successful you can always use
linkedin and try out a few gadgets
created by microsoft to promote your
skills and be a step ahead of everyone
else after you're done looking at the
company museum and exploring stuff you
can always buy a souvenir from the
microsoft apparel store stuffed toys
keychains t-shirts shoes glasses
whatever you want name it they have it
microsoft walk of fame
and as we said earlier the gods of
microsoft have tried to make the
microsoft campus extremely interesting
and have used their innovation too
related to pop culture as well so just
like the hollywood walk of fame there
are panels outside building 16 and no
there is nothing nerdy about them well
except for a little each panel in the
microsoft walk of fame depicts a certain
launch that was considered a very
important milestone in the journey of
the success of microsoft speaking of
success did you know that microsoft
ranks number 21 in the 2020 fortune 500
rankings of the largest united states
corporations according to revenue
building eight
enough talk about work let's talk about
something else did you know that
building eight is the place where the
owner of microsoft the shy nerd bill
gates met his future wife melinda for
the first time is this a wattpad love
story or what according to articles and
the couple themselves both bill and
melinda were working overtime while
everyone else was back at home
apparently the shine nerd used to
silently observe his pretty colleague
working overtime had gotten used to her
timetable
one day when the coast was clear mr
gates shot his shot and asked her out
the rest is history quite literally
anyways the couple is now divorced so
let's go back to the tour of the
insanely large headquarters of microsoft
also if you're a visitor and someone
asks you to come to building 7 politely
tell them you cannot why because
building 7 doesn't really exist building
7 is a myth like the bigfoot in the
microsoft campus there are several
theories about why there isn't a
building 7. some people say that they
could not construct a building 7 because
of a government permit others say that
they forgot to number the building 7
while the other people call the innocent
newbies to building 7 and prank them
building 87
now let's move on to something a little
more interesting building 87 this might
seem a little concerning yet awesome at
the same time how because building 87 is
the place where all the top secret
research happens we're not sure if
visitors are allowed down there because
there are several eyebrow raising
projects like the orwellian sounding
department of human data and the
hypnotic noise suppressing anechoic
chamber who knows what goes on in there
it's like willy wonka's chocolate
factory but make it nerdy and all about
technology and software but the good
news is that visitors in the microsoft
campus won't be eliminated one by one as
it happened in the movie
the maker's garage now let's move on to
the next part of the microsoft campus
that is a beautiful reminder of how
important and crucial creativity and
experimentation is no matter what field
you are in we're talking about the
maker's garage where all the engineers
mess around with their ideas am i proud
of the garage
i'm more than proud i'm happy that there
is a garage here the garage is your
toolbox
for shaping your ideas into products if
you're done with work and you feel like
the idea that has been nagging you for
quite some time has a decent potential
then the microsoft management has
provided the employees with a maker's
garage where all the necessary gadgets
and facilities like the laser cutters 3d
printers soldering gears etc are
available also quite opposite to what
most people think about engineers that
all they do is wear thick glasses and
sit in front of a computer all day and
geek around microsoft has done quite a
decent arrangement for the physical
health of its workers as well there are
two soccer pitches several basketball
courts softball nets beach volleyball
and a lot of running trails and do you
remember in the start when we mentioned
that the microsoft headquarters is
called a campus so just like traditional
university campuses there are ping pong
tables and pool tables present as well
now whenever the employees there are
exhausted and overworked they can always
put on their joggers and go for a run
and if they feel a little sporty they
can always play soccer with their
friends now let's move on to one of the
most interesting and awesome parts of
the microsoft campus did you know that
there was a gigantic maul there that's
right ladies and gentlemen the commons
mall is a two-story building with 1.4
million square feet and tons of stuff
that you normally might not find in a
workplace
the commons mall
now who would have thought that a
technology company would have an entire
mall inside everyone thinks that when
you're working for a technology company
all you have to do is sit in front of a
screen be in meetings or in the lab that
is pretty much all but the gods of
microsoft have proven this concept wrong
by including an entire mall in the plan
of their headquarters and what does the
mall have
everything if you're tired you can
always grab a refreshing and recharging
cup of coffee and if you feel like
munching on something there is pretty
much everything you could feel like
eating inside the mall in fact if you
feel like eating local food then thanks
to the new initiative of the microsoft
management local businesses are being
supported and endorsed inside the
commons mall if you want to get your
bike fixed if you want to get your phone
fixed if you want to get a haircut if
you want to buy a new dress or if you
think that you need a new dinner set
everything is available in the commons
mall well we might have exaggerated a
little everything isn't available you
might be able to get any technology
there but don't expect to find the
latest iphone or a macbook there they
don't have the best relations you know
the treehouse offices
now let's talk about something childish
but extremely professional and amusing
that's right we're talking about the
treehouse offices and meeting rooms
inside microsoft employees sit and chat
at a long wooden table quite recently to
encourage a healthy work environment
they have constructed office rooms on
top of tree houses this way whenever
you're exhausted by a board meeting and
are tired of explaining your project to
your executives you can always step out
and breathe some fresh air not only that
you can enjoy and relax a little by
listening to the chirping of the birds
and overall the fresh environment will
improve your mood for sure
the lake bill
since we're talking about the fun parts
of the microsoft campus let's talk about
lake bill as you have guessed this lake
is for celebrating and can you guess why
every time a new microsoft product
exceeds the expectations of the
executives or does exceptionally well in
the market everyone celebrates by
witnessing one of the richest people on
the planet jump in the lake and get
drenched that is quite a wholesome and
interesting way to celebrate your
accomplishments
the high five hallway
in this hallway all you have to do is
smile at other people and give them a
high five therefore we won't advise you
to go through the hallway if you're
having a bad day because who wants to
give a high five when they had a burnt
toast in the morning or why would you
want to smile at random people when you
woke up to your dog pooping in your bed
exactly make sure to hit the like and
subscribe button and don't forget to
turn on post notifications i'll see you
in the next video